[Musique]
le cartable des écoliers est il trop
lourd
oui incontestablement en règle générale
est pourtant une circulaire
ministérielle interdit aux instituteurs
de donner des devoirs à la maison
pourtant une constatation s'impose les
petits ont souvent des cartables
beaucoup trop importants pour leur
taille et le peu de choses qu'ils ont à
y mettre
tu as l'air d'avoir un très gros
cartable est ce que ça te dirait de nous
montrer ce qu'il ya dedans non est ce
qu'on fait on va le mettre par terre
tout ça allez on va le voir alors que
des lignes 3 satyana des livres de voir
arriver le parterre de trois ans vit
dans ce cd mes amis c'est ce qui fait
partie du matériel scolaire tout ça des
beatles venus france gall ça c'est tout
un matériel alors pas tout à fait à la
moitié avant et pourquoi on porte tous
des disques en acier un tourne-disque
dans la classe maintenant y'a pas de ton
avis mais apte à faire mieux comment
vous faire mieux j'aime c'est comme ça
qu'ils ont montré aux camarades
rapidement qu'au delà du ventre ça aux
copains pendant la récréation fédération
en classe a et pendant qu'elle part
qu'elles courent un calcul le français n
importe mais le cartable que l'on nomme
ensuite serviette et souvent le
compagnon inséparable d'une vie anonyme
ou d'une destinée particulièrement
brillante
il est souvent un témoin un gardien des
affaires dites inhérente de l'état il
suit il accompagne il précède même
quelquefois en regardant ces cartables
anonyme
vous souvenez-vous de ce qu'il y avait
dans le vôtre lorsque vous étiez enfant
aviez des petites choses personnelles
aux deux petites conneries c'est à dire
des blagues ouais on avait un petit
goûter on avait des petites images de
petites choses pour distraire
comment est ce qu'on dit de perdigon
petites choses pour le goûter les joies
je recevais petites choses qu'on m'aide
à réfléchir on vous en faisiez la classe
je mettais des photos tout est bien
délicat de bandes dessinées des choses
comme ça bon goûter beaucoup d'image
bienvenue les images dans le temps et
genre de carte postale vous savez que
représentait des petites histoires le
petit chaperon rouge est une règle en
fer parce que sa seule charge à lui a
tapé sur les copains chanter vous voyez
donc qu'à travers le contenu d'un simple
cartable d'écolier transparaissent la
personnalité et le caractère ces petites
réflexions nous ont amenés pour finir à
demander à des gens connus de nous
parler de leurs cartables à eux c'est
ainsi que nous avons rencontré jacques
baudouin marcel pagnol fernandel et
gaston bonheur qui a passé son enfance
dans la région de narbonne où les
cartables qu'il a connue était
particulièrement savoureux que dans
celle de la saison il y avait jusqu'à
grille aurait une feuille de salade ou
une cigale
même un petit lézard cesser les attaques
on appelait les de saint georges des
petits lézards glee qui viennent chez
nous il y avait vivait en revanche quand
on tuer le cochon qui était le grand la
grande fête des paysans il y avait le
présent c'est ainsi qu'on appelle le
cadeau qu'ont apporté de la maîtrise
honneur en quoi consiste-t-il pour jeter
des morceaux de boudin ou ou des pâtes
et d'oreilles enfin du pâté de tête
séoul a cédé le morceau du filet de
cochon à mesure que le cycle des études
s'avance le continu du cartable ou
diminuent se veut dire le contenu
récréatif parce qu'il ya davantage de
livres il ya moins de place pour
s'amuser
enfin au début à l'école primaire au
moment où il n'avait qu'une ardoise vous
pensez si j'avais de la place alors en
automne j'avais démarrons par exemple au
printemps j'avais des hannetons vous
savez ce qu'on peut faire avec des
haltes ont fait des choses merveilleuses
ça s'envole on les trempe dans l'ancrage
est très amusant si j'avais aussi non
seulement c'était un vivarium mais
c'était aussi un garde-manger alors
savez j'avais des tubes de coco j'avais
des kroumirs les kroumirs dans le midi
ce sont des petits personnages en règle
et se savait
et puis je suis jamais allé jusqu au
saucisson et au litre de vin rouge quand
même et puis alors j'ai eu aussi mais
alors au titre du vivarium un cochon
d'inde qui s'appelait falzar et qui
était très bien nourris d'ailleurs au
point qu'il avait tellement gré c'est
que j'ai été obligé de le faire passer
en résidence forcée secondaire dans mon
pupitre donc le cartel n'a pas été pour
vous votre premier coffre-fort à secrets
d'euros non non je voulais j'habite dans
l'école
ce sont les petits pensionnés a qui ont
des coffres-forts à petit trait au lycée
c'est à lison le casier dans lequel elle
parfois des souris blanche je l'avais
fait vous oui je lui fais lorsque
j'étais devenue pensionnaire je fais des
vers à soie dans mon casier
ici on a ouvert nos cartables de
fernandel enfants qu'est-ce qu'on aurait
trouvé beaucoup de choses
il ya d'abord les livres un livre
indispensable soit quand nous obliger à
porter parce qu'il le fallait pour la
classe il y avait aussi d'autres livres
mais c'est des livres que je lisais moi
même en classe c
les buffalo bills le héros du far west
où notre pain quart temps le plus
illustre est active de nos jours on
avait le petit ami avec la petite poche
ici c'est sympa tu es plus que le barça
vos chroniques c'est surtout ça je vous
regardez le poil à gratter n'était pas
le cartable où il y avait les mouches
les machins les mouches qui volent et
avec le papier à kayes et les trois
couleurs mettions vous savez on les a
vus il avait des x 30 la classe comme
pour donner le signal
il doit dire que j'étais un des chefs
d'ailleurs pour donner le signal
[Musique]